this is what vaccination fatigue looks
like
since july vaccination centers in
germany are nowhere near as busy as they
were when the campaign kicked off in the
spring
at the same time germany still needs at
least 5 million vaccinations to make it
safely through the fall
around 190 000 jabs are administered
every day
the figure needs to be three times as
many
[Music]
this is your coveted 19 special here on
dw i'm janelle demalaon here in germany
the slowing pace of inoculations has
forced authorities to find creative ways
to get things back on track have a look
this is not a typical train ride it's a
new way to drive a vaccination rates
in an effort to persuade unvaccinated
residents in berlin the string was
converted into a mobile covet 19
vaccination center
onboard the moving train this physician
administers the single shot johnson and
johnson jab
now that it's done and relaxed i'm very
happy and proud that i'm done now and
with only one shot
sure my arm hurts a bit but i feel fine
is the number of new vaccinations
flattened in germany the country's rail
operator is trying out something new
today we have a first come first serve
method those who board will get a shot
we want to see whether the offer will be
accepted
that's why andreas wanted to arrive
early at the trap tower park train
station a friend told him about this
campaign
i thought why not as it is on the train
and you simply have to hop on and sit
there and wait to be called that's it
that's easier for me than having to go
to make a doctor's appointment
[Music]
but his hopes of getting his shot on the
train quick and easy faded once the
train arrived
so many people took interest in a one
day campaign that he and many others had
to be left behind due to lack of space
for some it was a successful train ride
but berlin's transit system may have
underestimated how popular it would be
the city has been getting more creative
with ways to increase the vaccination
rate and several residents here hope
more vaccine trains will be scheduled
down the line
now just to get you up to speed as to
the number of coronavirus vaccine doses
administered so far here in germany
we're at 102
414
255.
those who have received one shot make up
65.8
percent of the population while those
who are fully vaccinated clock in at
close to 60 percent
now with those numbers in mind we are
joined by klaus star he's a virologist
and epidemiologist welcome to the
program dr ster you are also the
coordinator of the corona strategy
platform where you and other scientists
are developing plans to combat the
pandemic here in germany
tell us what can we expect
well
when it comes to autumn and winter this
year i think we are going to see a
significant increase in cases again with
a slight difference to last year this
year about 20 percent only of the
above 60 on are not yet immune so that
it's a it's a significant difference
much fewer cases can get and people can
get infected but 20 in germany are four
million people it's half the population
of switzerland above 60 which has not
yet been immunized so these people can
still become severely ill
the chance of a person who is above 80
to die from an infection is between 10
to 30 percent and nobody would hop on a
boat or train
without such an expectation of of dying
but there is a long way to go here and
there are also very many younger people
who have not yet gone through natural
immunization or immunization and there
can also be a large number of cases
during the winter period
now very important of course to set
those numbers in context as you've done
but we do see other countries with high
vaccination rates also having to deal
with high infection rates how does this
development inform germany's pandemic
strategy
i hope it would because germany has one
of the lowest incidences so the number
of cases per day
what that mean is that
there is no chance for those who do not
want to get immunized or who cannot be
immunized to to get natural immunization
many other countries have a type of
catch-up
effect now uh
incidences are at the area of 200 300
400 so all those people who are now
getting natural immunization with an
asymptomatic infection uh particularly
in children adolescent and younger
adults and they will in germany not go
through this and you push pretty much
all these natural immunizations into the
winter period
and that will certainly add to a
significant wave of infectious diseases
so germany will have to have a catch-up
here in in autumn also because of last
winter
where germany had very often an incident
half only or a quarter of what other
countries had so i believe the total
number of people were already immune by
juntos immunized another country that's
much higher than in germany and that's
why
the
chance the risk of severe outbreak
corona outbreak again in winter is
pretty high
certainly a warning there for us now
you've called for an independent panel
of experts in a national commission to
advise policymakers does that mean you
think german policy has been badly
advised perhaps
well um what you normally do when you're
in a large entity in a society or an
institution or industry you have a
crisis management committee
with an expert advisory group that gives
you uh
policy options you ask for three options
possibly one which focuses on health one
on uh economy and one on
the
democratic rights you ask for the
control option to be developed
the policy maker you want to know what
are the advantages and disadvantages of
these options at the end you have to
make a decision and the group which
developing these options is a
multi-disciplinary
team composed not only of
patient remote virologists and
epidemiologists like me but also on
pediatricians
internist people who are working in
public health on the ground who are
making decisions on on hospital
hygiene who are advising hopes for the
elderly and retirement home that such
independent advisory committee is
necessary to develop in a structured
risk assessment process the the uh the
strategy uh to um
as options for the government to decide
that such a committee did not exist and
the only one actually which does exist
which is the advisory committee on
immunization practices has been severely
politically undermined
by demands from politicians that they
should make it a decision in such favor
and against this and without this this
committee having the freedom and the
right and the
mandated task to make an independent
assessment so such an advisory committee
i think could have helped the government
a lot also when looking at for instance
what is the risk of the uh variants uh
what is the our children and
schools drivers of the pandemic well
there are very many questions where an
independent advisory could have helped
claustra is a virologist and
epidemiologist thank you very much for
your time today
thank you
now here's a look at some of the other
stories making news around the world
a key world cup qualifying soccer match
between brazil and argentina was
suspended on sunday night in unusual
circumstances brazilian health officials
walked onto the pitch at the corinthians
arena and stopped the game just five
minutes in they objected to the
participation of three argentine players
they say brokovic 19 quarantine rules
venezuela is expecting its first
deliveries of coronavirus vaccines
obtained by the kovac system after
months of stalled attempts to obtain
inoculations through the global vaccine
program so far venezuela has been
inoculating its population with doses
acquired directly from china and russia
following months of delays and making
payments to kovacs
and now it's time for one of your
questions here's our science
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
i've been vaccinated twice but still got
coveted 19. will the vaccine at least
have my immune system fight it off so
you did the right thing to protect
yourself and others and you got
vaccinated
and you thought you were safe
and then you got the virus anyway um if
you're a breakthrough case then you're
not alone
it's a regular occurrence and it will
continue to happen
to plenty of people um certainly in
societies where large percentages of the
population remain
unvaccinated and transmission is high
but it's important to emphasize
that breakthrough infections were
expected
although approved vaccines had
high levels of efficacy and trials um
some amazingly high no vaccine is 100
percent effective at preventing disease
in everyone and
and that's not what our first generation
vaccines even attempted to do
they were designed to prevent people
from ending up in an intensive care unit
with covet 19 and and the data we have
shows that they continue to do that
very very well
so what can you expect if you have a
breakthrough infection well
one really excellent resource the zoe
symptoms study which is an app-based
project that collects data directly from
patients in britain
they're the most commonly reported
symptoms and fully vaccinated people
are in order of prevalence headache
runny nose sneezing sore throat
and a loss of smell it's not really all
that different actually than symptoms
unvaccinated people reported
although they were more likely to have a
fever and a persistent cough as well
but and and this is key
what all of the experts i read agree on
is that in fully vaccinated covid19
patients
any symptoms are generally
much less severe and and shorter lived
because nothing is ever 100
a few breakthrough patients are of
course also ending up in hospitals but
but current evidence indicates strongly
that the vaccines are still very
effectively doing what they were
designed to do which is
to prevent severe illness in people who
received them
by priming the immune system to to beat
off an attack
by sars cov2
[Music]
you